welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
latest trailer for ghostbusters
afterlight a sequel from director jason
reitman son of the director of the
original films ivan reitman and actually
a kid who cameoed in ghostbusters too
you know my dad said you guys are full
of crap and that's why you went out of
business and that parent child
connection has inspired this film
something jason wrightman actually went
into in a special director's breakdown
he did with ign but here at new
rockstars we cross the streams and find
all the stuff we're not supposed to find
yet busting every hidden ghost because
busting makes us feel good yeah i know
how that sounds let's do this let's
break down all the easter eggs you
missed in this trailer we open in
somerville oklahoma hometown of egon
spangler the late harold remus and the
destination of his daughter callie
carrie [ __ ] and her two children trevor
finn wolfhard and phoebe mckenna grace
who clearly takes after her grandfather
with similar hair in the same circular
glasses but somerville was actually the
town spangler mentioned in the animated
series headless horseman episode as his
hometown phoebe finds a classic
ghostbusters trap under the floorboards
but it must have been hidden there by
her grandfather with this complex
configuration of having to slide the
floor tiles around like a puzzle making
me wonder if something's trapped inside
that trap that he didn't want to or
couldn't store with the other vapers and
entities in the ecto containment unit
now jason reitman said that he designed
the roof of spengler's house to reflect
the top of the ecto-1 both of them
covered in arrays of sensors and other
devices we see a photo of the original
lineup egon spangler ray stance peter
venkman and winston zetamore with dan
aykroyd tourney hudson and even bill
murray confirmed to appear in this film
along with sigourney weaver as dana and
of course annie potts returns as janine
still rocking her colorful glasses like
the ones she would wear when she was the
ghostbusters secretary your father
wasn't much of a homemaker he could
hardly keep the power on remember janine
and egon had a bit of a flirty
relationship in the previous films so
maybe they ended up getting married in
their later years or at least she was
just a caretaker to him in his old age
she mentions he struggled to keep the
power on recalling the way the
ghostbusters would drain energy from the
power grid for their ecto container
trevor finds the ecto-1 and repairs it
takes it joyriding through the wheat
field rightman actually said after
shooting this they could smell roasted
barley on the engine phoebe has to
research her grandfather and the other
ghostbusters from their commercials from
the 80s on youtube trevor finds egon's
pke meter and in a walmart we get this
adorable scene where paul read as mr
gooberson sees the stay puft minis
partying it up two are rolling a can
away a whole bunch of others are riding
a roomba one pokes the other with an
umbrella skewer now i like how the one
on the left shoves a piece of candy in
the other's mouth making him a little
bit fatter and you can see him cringe
like he's not sure how he feels about
that and then one turns himself into a
s'more and just looks so goddamn cozy
under that chocolate weighted blanket i
mean honestly that's how i'd want to go
i could be wrong but it looks like paul
rudd is holding a pint of baskin robbins
ice cream which if so would be a nod to
scott lang's day job in ant-man
baskin-robbins would be well aware of
the ghostly conspiracy this town because
baskin-robbins always finds out now if
you don't agree with where i'm going
with this or if you don't always agree
with my take on this stuff okay smart
guy you go make your own counterpoint
youtube video with wondershare filmora
wondershare filmora is easy to use and
perfect for both beginners and
experienced editors alike it has preset
templates like effects and filters and
royalty-free music pump out a video in
about 10 minutes filmora just released
version 10.5 with new features like auto
reframe and ar stickers let me show you
how it works here just drag and drop
your clip on the editing track and start
editing one feature we really appreciate
new rockstars is the audio normalization
want to get into content creation but
don't know how to start well download
wondershare filmora 10 in the
description below and try it for free
the free trial will have a watermark but
if you comment with what you think of
the newest version of filmora or share
your own video creation using
createwithfilmora and tag newrockstars
on twitter the filmora team will pick a
lucky winner from each to give away a
one-year free license so thanks again to
wondershare filmora for sponsoring this
video trevor and his friends hang out on
the property of the shandor mining
company which is a nod to ivo shandor
the architect who designed the building
that served as the gateway to gozer in
the original film the whole building
is a huge superconductive antenna that
was designed and built expressly for the
purpose of pulling in and concentrating
spiritual turbulence the architect's
name was evo shandor i found it in
tobin's spirit guide actually in that
seed stan said that the girders were
made of a rare selenium cold riveted
girders
with cores of pure selenium which could
have been mined here in oklahoma and as
the kids descend into the mine there is
a statue of gozer flanked by upright
statues of the terror dogs so maybe the
reason spangler moved here was to
investigate other gateways that ivo
shandora and the rest of the gozer cult
might have constructed before they moved
to new york city and if there's one here
there might be many scattered all over
the world and as the hell mouth opens
the demon clawing out is absolutely
gozer you cannot mistake that haircut
pink streams burst from the hell mouth
spread all over the town jason whiteman
actually said they scanned the original
visual effect from the 1984 film and
mapped it into this film to give
everything the same iconic look and make
this film feel so directly linked to the
production design of the two 80s films
same goes for the patron at the diner
notice how he wears old-timey minor
clothes and a hat with a light on it he
probably was a chandor mining company
employee reitman actually said his
design was a throwback to the taxi
driver ghost in the 84 film now in
addition to the tarot dogs on foot this
movie will show their spectral form
since their bodies are actually vessels
for astral spirits underneath but as the
terror dog chases paul rudd out of the
walmart it slips and slides a bit
clumsily just like it does in the 84
film reitman actually said they studied
footage of the running of the bulls in
spain in order to animate it here the
ecto-1 skids around a corner reikman set
a throwback to the shot of the ecto-1u
u-turning out of the firehouse in the
first film it passes a stay-puft
marshmallow mural which is kind of a
weird ad to have considered in this
world the new york city incident
actually happened i'm wondering if
someone could have painted this as
either a tribute or a way to troll egon
spangler after he relocated here phoebe
fires her proton packs stream from a
gunner seat while they use a trap rigged
up as an rc car it's pretty clever this
could have been another one of egon's
devices and they're chasing not slimer
but a new ghost for this movie called
muncher which reitman said was the
result of several conversations about
designing a ghost that was specific to
the world of ghostbusters now there is a
running belief that slimer in the
original film was written to be the
ghost of their friend and colleague john
belushi and now that we get a look at
muncher's face i gotta wonder if they
might be doing a similar thing in this
movie with this face being just a really
gross morphed inhuman rendition of one
of the iconic faces of the original cast
now i originally thought bill murray
since he has stated in the past that he
would only return if he got to play a
ghost but a few months back he did say
in an interview that his experience
shooting the film was physically painful
because he had to wear a proton pack
that was super uncomfortable he could
have been joking around the guy is kind
of hard to read obviously but if it's
not him i am wondering if muncher could
actually be the ghosted egon spangler a
way to pay tribute to harold ramus as
the way they pay tribute to john belushi
another shot of them watching
ghostbusters commercials on youtube but
this time you can see the recommended
videos 10 signs the government is run by
shandorians suggesting that people in
this world believe the cult of ivo
shandor the gozer worshipers have
corrupted high ranking members of
government then where are the
ghostbusters now and it looks like
there's present day images of dan
aykroyd and bill murray then proton
acceleration with megan amram amram is a
comedy writer from shows like the good
place and parks and rec and savage
science of the proton pack with adam
savage from mythbusters with a still
that looks like it's from his tested
video on youtube where he wore his
ghostbusters jumpsuit and we end with
this
we're closed yes this is dan aykroyd
race dance and he's actually in his
bookstore from the second movie you can
see occult books on the window there and
he has his red phone on the counter like
he had in the first film now on his arm
is a tattoo it says revelation 7 12
which is a callback to rey's
conversation with winston in the first
movie i remember revelation 7 12
and i looked as he opened the sixth seal
and behold there was a great earthquake
now actually that verse is supposed to
be revelation 6 12 but they kept the
tattoo at 7 12 just to stay true to the
mistake which you just gotta respect
this was one of many titles that was
supposed to come out last year i was
bummed to see you get delayed and i
cannot wait to see it this november in
the meantime you can support this
channel by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos follow and subscribe to
new rockstars for breakdowns of
everything you love thank you for
watching and now all you nostalgic
fanboys can get back to busting busting
busting busting i know you were
[Music]
you